a volunteer group is planting trees at
five different parks they plan to 90
trees at each Park how many trees did
the plant did the group plant at all so
here's what we know we know that this
group went to five different parts very
kind of them and plan to ninety trees at
each of those parks so if we want to
know the total amount we could do a
couple things we could say they plan to
90 trees a park one plus ninety Moore
Park two plus you see where this is
going 90 Moore Park three plus ninety
Moore Park four and finally ninety Moore
Park five so one way to solve this would
be to add all of those 90s we could do
it it'll take a while but we could get
there or we could say that the group
plan to ninety trees five times five
times they planted ninety trees so
ninety times five let's solve both of
these either great ways to get to our
solution but maybe solving both of them
will help us see if we liked one way
better if one felt simpler for us so
ninety number ninety we can think of as
nine tens I'll write that up there and
that'll help us add nine tens plus nine
tens of eighteen tens plus nine more
tens is twenty seven tens plus nine more
tens is thirty six tens and the last
nine tens gets us forty five tens or
four hundred fifty that zero is because
we're talking about tens forty five tens
or four hundred fifty so the group
planted four hundred and fifty trees now
let's try the multiplication way and see
how that goes
so again ninety ten ninety we can think
of as nine tens times five so if you
have nine tens five times you have forty
five tens and forty five tens is again
four hundred fifty get that zero on the
end both ways we see this is a very
generous group they planted four hundred
and
50 trees either way we could add or we
could multiply for me the multiplication
gets me there faster I like the
multiplication way but either way we can
see 90 trees at five parks is 450 total
trees